Welcome back everyone
Marvel just dropped a trailer for
I Am Groot Season 2.
There are five new short episodes
they're releasing in this season.
There's a whole bunch more crossover
going on with the Watcher.
Returning from what if?
Also, explain
what's going on with what if season two
and how that connects
with all the multiverse stuff
like Loki Season 2 Avengers 5
Kang Dynasty in Alpha Groot with Rocket's,
New Guardians of the Galaxy team.
So if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get everything.
There's an interesting connection here
with the Watcher in the new Fantastic
Four movie two that I'll explain.
But all the episodes are dropping
at the same time.
It'll be just like season
1 together they amount to
about a single regular length episode.
I know there's some timeline questions
about when this takes place compared to
what if because the watcher is here
now, supposedly he's in multiple episodes.
It's not just meant to be a one off
two second blink
and you'll miss a kind of cameo.
Season 2
is supposed to start a little while
after the end of season one
that took place
between the end of Guardians of the Galaxy
two and the final Post-Credits scene
when Groot grew up two teenage Groot sides
and sort of dropping F-bombs
left and right.
in they're also flying their ship
the Benatar pass the watcher here
that's the ship that they got
during Avengers Infinity War.
But this confirms
that when the watcher appears
during the episodes
this is meant to be earlier
in his timeline before the events of
what if season one the watchers
raise are extremely long lived.
He's not a god, but he's nigh immortal.
They're just super powerful cosmic beings
with a highly evolved race
They did make some changes to his
character during whatever season one.
They made him the watcher
of the entire multi verse
instead of just the main MCU 616 universe.
In the comics
there are an entire race of beings
all about the same level of power,
but different ages.
like Uatu, the main
watcher of the comics has a father
like he was born to parents in.
They all are assigned different planets
in the single universe,
like the main Marvel Universe
to watch over. watch?
Who is assigned by his race
to watch over Earth?
Just the one planet inside the 616
Marvel Universe.
They're not meant to be multiversal
beings.
Meaning that there's a different version
of the watchers in each universe
during whatever season one
they had the main watcher the comics
want to watching the entire multiverse
and they dealt with this
at the end of the season but the watchers
oath is for noninterference.
He literally is only supposed to watch
events unfold never take part During
What if they did the episode?
What if the watcher broke his oath
and interfered to try and stop Ultron,
who had assembled all six Infinity stones
and taken Vision's body
to become what they were
calling the Infinity Ultron?
The only reason he stepped in then
is because he felt,
had he not, Ultron would have destroyed
the entire multiverse.
All of reality, which is kind of
what's happening in Avengers
five, Qing Dynasty in Avengers
six Secret Wars.
Anyway, hold on a second.
We can't destroy the entire multiverse
for a couple of more movies
I just did a video for the new Fantastic
Four movie that they're making,
and the interesting connection
with the Fantastic Four is that
the Watcher appeared for the first time
in Fantastic four comics issue number 13.
In the early 1960s.
soon after.
Then he broke his oath for the first time
when he confronted Galactus
when he was introduced.
Also in those early Fantastic
Four comics during a story
called The Coming of Galactus.
in the new live action MCU, Fantastic
Four movie Galactus
is supposed to be the main villain,
so we might actually see the Watcher
used to debut in live action
during Fantastic Four.
Now you'll remember
we already saw the Watchers race in live
action during Guardians of the Galaxy
two, bringing things back around to Groot
and the other Guardians.
Stan Lee was canonized
as an agent of the Watchers.
Like that was the big joke
of his post-credits scene.
James Gunn was paying off
a long running fan theory
that went back to the original Marvel
Phase one movies like
Back to the first Iron Man movie that Stan
Lee was meant to be the same character
in all of his different cameos.
Just acting in his role
as an agent of the Watchers
sent to observe now
what if it's
meant to be candid to the MCU?
So I'm assuming they'll explain why
there are whole race of watchers.
But who?
What do has to watch the entire multiverse
seemingly by himself.
but at the beginning of the trailer,
big Easter egg.
Here you see
group playing with a Nova action figure.
I know everybody's asking
when they're going to finally do Nova
in live action
before Marvel pump the brakes on how fast
they were cranking out movies
and Disney Plus series.
There were reports of then doing a Nova
Disney Plus series, then a
one off special presentation,
kind of like werewolf by Night
they might still do that.
But the idea is that Kevin Foggy
said that they will eventually introduce
the character, so they will do Nova
there was even a huge deleted scene
of Nova during Avengers Infinity War
and then later during Avengers Endgame
there's a few Easter eggs here
on this alien ice cream ship,
like the spaceship version
of an ice cream truck, which also plays
the same ice cream truck type of music
meant to lure people out.
Now, because of all the movies,
like all the horror films that I've seen,
it seems kind of like the starting
of something really sinister.
Don't go towards the sound, Groot.
Stay away from the truck.
you notice, they have a Howard,
the duck themed ice cream.
Maybe Howard The duck will appear
during the I Am Groot episodes.
We see Groot stealing a ship
to get the ice cream weird thing too.
Here you also see Groot construct
his own giant robot on one of the plants
they go to.
He's supposed to be intelligent,
but I never thought of him being this
smart when he was still baby Groot.
There is an explanation for this
in the comics, though.
The movies have changed the way
Groot and baby Groot work.
But in the comics, the original Groot can
just regrow himself from a single twig.
So if he were a baby Groot in the comics,
he was still all the memories
in the intelligence of the original Groot.
but in the first Guardians of the Galaxy
movie, James Gunn said that he wanted
Groot sacrificed to stick to make
as many tree Groot puns as possible.
He didn't want to immediately
take that back.
so, he said, The new Groot is meant to be
like the child of the original Groot.
So he has totally new memories.
He doesn't remember anything
about original groups, life
or his adventures with Rocket
before he met the Guardians of the Galaxy.
That's why in present day Alpha Groot,
like the Giga Chad version of Groot,
has a totally different personality.
Lois Playing video games.
He's way more sociable
with the rest of the team,
like he's way more adjusted to life
with humans because he's been living
with them his entire life.
James Gunn actually said
that he wrote the story of How Rocket met
the original Groot with the intention of
doing a spinoff movie for the two of them.
It would have happened sometime
after the first Guardians
of the Galaxy movie came out,
but eventually he just shelved it
and continue with the Normal Trilogy.
This is what he said about it.
I wrote a short film explaining the origin
of how Rocket and Groot met.
It was even storyboarded in location
scouted. We did test footage for it.
It was seen at San Diego
Comic-Con in the trailer
we cut together after 12 days of shooting.
Let me know if you were in Hall
H in the Comic-Con audience
and saw that trailer footage
because they didn't release it online.
Then he goes on to say,
But I didn't have time to do it as Volume
1 amped up in it, Tibius Lark, Groot
and Rocket were all imprisoned in a deep
well on the ground.
Tibius was on the verge of dying.
He explained to Rocket that he had been
caring for Groot for years in an alien
zoo. Tibius was meant to be a former
zookeeper in a galactic zoo,
He explained that he had saved Groot,
who was there on exhibit,
and Groot was a loyal friend.
He asked Rocket to
please take care of him.
And then he died.
As he died, Rocket
looked down in the dark cell
and noticed that he was actually a robot.
The lower part of his body
smashed open and mechanical.
the guards above ground
heard something rumbling
and then they turned and saw Rocket
and Groot bursting up from the ground
rocket on Groot shoulder like you saw
in all the Guardians of the Galaxy movies.
They did that a couple of times,
repeating the shot,
they even reversed it with Groot on Rocket
Shoulder at one point
and in Rockets hands was a machine gun
made from Tibius Lark's body.
And he shot all the guards.
They escaped and were together
until they met the Guardians.
If you remember, Rocket
is actually meant to be a genius.
James Gunn Explain.
During Guardians of the Galaxy three,
if it wasn't already apparent he also made
Nebula's brand new arm in Guardians
of the Galaxy three on his own.
I think that was meant to be his.
Thank you for her bringing him
winter soldier's arm still
wondering how Winter Soldier is going
to get another arm or get that arm back.
Maybe Rocket just took it back to him
at some point.
The funny thing about that, too,
is that people went crazy about this
when the Guardians of the Galaxy holiday
special came out and James Gunn literally
on Twitter was like, Nope, it's Cannon.
She just went and ripped it
right off in the middle of the night.
they'll explain that
when he shows up again during the
Thunderbolts movie, like, Man, this crazy
chick came, tore my arm right off.
But then another raccoon came
and brought it back to me.
in related Marvel Animated news.
There's a bunch of upcoming
animated series they have like X-Men 97,
which is kind of like an X-Men
animated series, Season six.
It's just a continuation of
the original X-Men, the animated series.
they just showed off a teaser trailer at
Comic-Con, but they didn't posted online
before the delays that was supposed
to release early January 20, 24.
We'll see if that still happens.
What if season two was also delayed
is pretty much ready to go?
They're like it's sitting on a shelf
somewhere.
It'll still come out at some point
during 2024 Spider-Man freshman year.
Season one is probably going
to get released either
at the end of next year or early 2025.
In the same for the Marvel Zombies
Season one, they should have trailers
for all these series
last year at Comic-Con,
I did trailer videos for all of them,
so I'll post them in the links below.
We'll probably get an official X-Men
97 trailer this year.
Later, after Loki season two in a new
What if season two trailer?
Of course
they'll do videos for everything.
So post all your requests,
your big questions
in the comments below click here for that
full Loki Season two trailer
and click here to learn about that
brand new Marvel Fantastic Four movie.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!